welcome to the brand-new trivia and
Easter egg show I'm your host definition
and this is where we break down our top
tented bits of trivia about all of the
latest movies throughout this video
we'll be going over Toy Story 4 to let
you know some amazing insights about the
film there may be some spoilers here so
if you haven't seen the movie yet then I
highly recommend a turn off now but
without the way thanks for clicking this
video now sit back relax and let's get
into our top 10 breakdown
number 10 mr. Potato Head unfortunately
in 2017 voice of mr. Potato Head at don
rickles passed away before he had the
opportunity to record his lines for Toy
Story 4 however at the request of
Rickles family who were desperate to see
the character in the film
Disney Pixar went back and created his
performance in the new movie from a
mixture of recordings from the last
three films Toy Story games theme park
rides and more number 9 movie
connections Pixar films often jam-packed
with Easter eggs and crossovers that tie
all of the universes together and Toy
Story 4 is no different in the movie boo
from Monsters Inc can be seen at several
points behind Bonnie as she creates for
ki in kindergarten
number 8 tin toys in addition to boo
teni from tin toy also appears in the
film for those who don't know tin toy is
the movie that starred it all and was
the first Pixar film ever created that
pretty much got studio funding to make
Toy Story it's great to see that even
after 30 years the studio still
remembers its roots number 7 up
connection in the marketing for the film
we can also see that there were several
other Easter eggs included in the
promotions such as the poster for the
film which contained the gambling dogs
picture from up it just goes to show how
widespread Pixar have become and is
always something to keep an eye out for
with every facet of these films number 6
- kaboom Toy Story 4 isn't just packed
with Easter eggs itself though and
characters from it have also appeared in
other Pixar films throughout the years
most notably do kaboom voiced by Keanu
Reeves appeared in The Incredibles - as
one of Jack Jack's
number five the matrix Pixar doesn't
just reference their own films either as
in the closing credits for the film
Jukka boom gets his mind blown and
announces whoa this is probably the most
famous line from The Matrix and has
become a catchphrase of Keanu Reeves
over the air since he first said it back
in 1999 number four are MRF 9/7
during one point of the film when Bo
Peep is taken away we can see that the
license plate on the car reads rmr F 97
this is a reference to a computer
command that Nalia raised all of Toy
Story 2 when the main file for the film
was nearly deleted off the servers at
Pixar it's great that they can laugh
about it now but imagine if they'd
actually lost all of that work sheesh
number three goosebumps the dummies in
the film are neat little Easter eggs for
goosebumps fans who will of course
remember slappy the dummy from the
series similar to slappy these dummies
have a sinister side and it's an amazing
callback for those who grew up on the
books the music played when the dummies
are introduced is midnight the Stars and
you which is the same song played in the
final scene of The Shining by Stanley
Kubrick and is also another tie-in to
the directors filmography that comes at
number two with 2001 a Space Odyssey
Buzz Lightyear has many recorded lines
that are tied directly to the buttons on
his chest including one which says open
the pod bay doors sci-fi fans will of
course instantly recognizes from Stanley
Kubrick's seminal space film 2001 a
Space Odyssey and it's a great little
callback to let us know that buzz really
has been to infinity and beyond number
one a soft remake and finally though Toy
Story 4 is not considered a remake or
reboot it does share a lot of
similarities to the first film in both
we follow characters who are convinced
that they are not toys and they becomes
stranded away from their owners with
Woody having to go out of his way to
rescue them overall it's an amazing
aesthetic that brings this franchise
full circle and it's the perfect way to
end the list obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this list and if
there's any other trivia that you'd like
to add then make sure you leave it in
the comments below this is a brand new
type of show that we're doing here at
the channel so if you enjoyed it then
make sure you give this video a thumbs
up
and don't forget to check out our full
breakdown of Toy Story fours ending
which would be linked at the end it
covers all of the aspects of the finale
as well as our thoughts on the film so
it's definitely worth checking out after
this video this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]